um i'm you know because we've done well
here on the show and uh you know that's
no secret to anyone and we're you know
grateful to all the fans for that
uh i've decided to get a personal
trainer and this is something that i
have put off doing for a long time and
uh and i it's out of fear but i finally
found somebody that i think
i connected with and somebody who i look
at as an example
of what i think i can do
and that's big to me to find someone who
i look at a certain body type but look
at somebody i go
that's out of reach or that's something
that i can't do but this is someone who
i met with we had a consultation
he understood my limitations and he he
understands the potential there
and uh
i'm excited about this and i think that
it'll be
it'll challenge me you know this will be
something that um
you know i don't
you know take lightly this is something
that i'm really gonna now really try to
do
with this person who i think who's i'm
fully committed and and they're fully
committed and they have represented some
people
you know and they've you know coached i
don't even know the term trained
some of the most famous people in the
world um
so this is
my personal trainer pat
i was ralph mae's personal trainer and
you see how that went he really tried to
pull the guy at least i got his money
yeah
well he did work with ralphie at the end
and i don't think we can look at the
results
i think we have to look at the journey
and i think the journey was valuable and
i think even though that didn't
necessarily end in a way that
you know
is positive i think
i don't think it's your fault i think
you certainly
did the best and what what are your
plans for me what should i really be i
mean looking forward to and what what
should i be kind of like focused on
lots of walking
yeah well we can do that
we certainly can do that but again this
is someone who gets me
and he gets
what i'm capable of
and so many trainers when i've met with
them don't and they push me
uh pat has said i don't really or
shouldn't even think about going to a
gym for three to four years
which i think is important to just kind
of start slow
and isn't that right pat you said i
should just really not push myself
and this is something that i'm not
trained lizzio to
yeah he's trained lizzo and he they're
getting very serious now
with lizzo you know and i saw
you know liza kind of walking you around
the mall and kind of pushing you around
and i think that's that's good that's
where i'm going to start
we're starting just kind of moving pat
through
certain
you know areas
it's amazing when you meet someone who
has a passion for fitness
that pat does because i have not you
know my whole life i haven't had one but
pat has kind of showed me that fitness
isn't
necessarily any one thing fitness could
mean many many things
and
the passion that he has
for fitness
and what he's been able to do at one
time i think he weighed over four or 500
pounds
and what he's been able to do
you know with his body is completely is
very impressive
um and i i am just in awe
of that and it's something that i want
to emulate
and this is breathing is even a workout
too yes yes breathing is
and that's what he told me because
breath control and breathing is is
probably the most important thing and
that i shouldn't
really get into weights or cardio to
just kind of just the in and the out
in and the out the in and the out
are you are you taking on any
new clients right now is there
is there anything that you're excited
about is there anything that you want to
promote are you promoting any fitness
programs because i don't want to keep
all this to myself
you know there's a lot of people out
there that need help and
one thing i've learned is that when you
have something good you want to give it
away you want to share it because that
becomes you know a really important
part of
the journey
of growth is not hoarding
the knowledge sharing it freely
with other people
and pat has a lot just you hopefully you
won't die like ralph did
well that's the goal
that is certainly the goal
but we go we go nice and slow
that's what we've learned slow and
steady wins the race
and that's what pat has always said we
don't want to move too quickly we don't
want to disrupt the systems
that we've come to rely on and uh
it's really amazing you know how you've
inspired me and i want to thank you
again
for everything that you've done
not only for me but for several other
people that in this business that you've
worked with and you know the trainers
don't get a lot of attention you know
nobody nobody calls
and says hey what a great job
but you've you've you've done a lot and
uh it's i really am i'm excited to to
work with you and to see where this
relationship goes i think it's just
going to be amazing and a lot of people
are
very excited that i've chosen pat
you know because a lot of people were
worried that i would choose you know one
of these la [ __ ]
trainers but i chose someone who i
believe is inspiring and committed it's
been an amazing uh
time we've worked together for two
months we haven't really
done anything yet
physically
but
the point is to really just kind of
fully you know he has me reading through
the history
of
gyms and personal fitness and exercise
writing a lot about that
and
you know just reading a lot of theory
and that's where i think
the other trainers don't work hard like
i do that's a good point a lot of them
don't and it's unfortunate
and it's something that
i think
you know is is really amazing is that
when you find somebody who who gets it
and uh i wanna thank you and i just
wanna i hope that you don't give up on
me
just don't give up on me
that's all i'm asking i know sometimes
it might be frustrating but
we're in this for the long haul i just
i'm i'm just hoping that you are in this
as well for the long haul with me this
is uh
you know it's just you're a spectacular
find
and uh i hope you're as committed to
this as i am
i will never give up on you but it's a
really good paycheck
well there you have it this is my new
personal trainer pat
thank you so much for everything we we
appreciate it and again if you're
interested in in training with pat
uh contact me via dm and we'll get you
his information because he's absolutely
one of the best
thank you so much
i took the helix quiz i was matched
with the firm mattress
because i sleep on my side and it's
great
i love it it's a huge upgrade it's
something that's very important
sleeping is one of the most important
things in life because you're rested
you're ready to take on everything
but a lot of people out there don't
sleep well
so they're insane
what do you think about sleeping
i love sleeping man it's the best
especially with helix it makes it a lot
more fun well helix makes your bed match
you perfectly
nice right
nice because here's what helix does
hey like better fill out a quiz and they
go oh this guy's an idiot
where would he want to sleep and then
they'd match him with the bed
that's right for someone who's
thoughtless head hits the pillow every
night
somebody like me they go oh we got to
get a bed for a genius
they have a 10-year warranty and you get
to try it out for 100 nights risk-free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't i mean this is in all actuality
all of my beds are helix they're easy
they come in the thing
you know
they ship them to you
i mean it's really good you have to they
have the pillows free pillows
they're offering up to 200 awful
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners
helixsleep.comtimd helixsleep.comd
go and get because here's the deal
they're cheap and they will ship them to
you and they're great beds yeah 10-year
warranty i've never heard of a just
having something like that and they can
do financing options which right now
with uh you know this huge great idea
you might want to keep that cash
i mean i think helix is just it's taking
over the market you know
sleep.com tim day
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the uh
tim dillon show that was our friend pat
pat our very funny friend pat
who uh
has a muscular dystrophy and we brought
him out to california my voice is going
and uh it's not covered we've i've
tested 95 times no cigarettes five days
um but you're gonna hear the voices uh
it's a little strained
but instead of abandoning you and giving
you nothing we're doing an episode but
that was our friend pat
who um
we flew out here uh with his mother and
his nurse
um to be a part of the show
and you know no one's going to write an
article about that but maybe they should
maybe they should
and maybe if you are in the press
and you want to write an article and
stop lying about the homes i have and
start saying who does more for people
with muscular dystrophy than tim dillon
right
is trash tuesday bringing out
cripples
no no no
no they are not no they are not
so of course i'm here
and i it's not and i don't do nice
things to keep bringing them up it's not
a big deal that we paid for the whole
thing and brought him out here with his
family it doesn't matter
it's something that anyone would have
done
and i'm not bringing it up
to to to basically try to get
goodwill from for myself or for the show
i'm what i'm stating is a fact
that we did a selfless act
and
when an act is selfless you don't need
to bring it up and we don't and i don't
i know i don't bring it up
i say one time what we did i tell you
one time what we did and then if you
want to go to the press you can go to
the press and i am available to do
interviews about it because it was a
nice thing to do
it was a sweetheart of a man and we like
him a lot
and um
his nurse was a little bit wacky
his nurse was a little wacky his nurse
now again with the nurses i'm telling
you right now
these nurses i'm telling you they're
i mean it's
i'm not even going into like hacky
covener [ __ ] that's for my special it'll
be out in seven months
but i'm telling you the nurses have to
be watched because this guy's nurse
ended up stealing his credit card and
then sucking dick for crack on sunset
boulevard at like three o'clock in the
morning this is true this is all true
and his nurse was on many drugs and
and it was very strange to me am i lying
no so far no lies
so far no lies so
i'm just saying we wish the best to
everyone involved because his nurse was
it was stunning
the nurse hadn't been a nurse for a
while and then they brought him back for
this like
i think they fired him because he was
doing drugs with the guy
and then they said you can't do drugs
with him and i think the nurse's
attitude was like who cares
it'll be fun
you know he's lived longer than we
thought he would live let's have a party
and then
um i think the parents were like let's
not do that
let's get out of here
and then they brought him back for this
one trip and they go oh we're going to
la
to do the tim dillon show we're going to
bring you on this trip and the nurse
then went buck wild as soon as he got
here he raided a minibar
he was insane
and he stole
the kid's credit card
and he smoked crack
and i believe he was sucking people off
for crack
this is
what i heard
and the guy has a voice app this guy pat
and at the lunch
the voice app would be he would be like
you know the nurse is i'm not going to
say the nurse's name but
whatever
the voice that would be like he is also
an alcoholic he drinks all day
and you would just be sitting there and
like looking at the nurse like
so
what are you gonna do but but a lot of
fun and very good very nice people
um
chessa boudin the san francisco
district attorney was just recalled they
had a recall election
for chessa burden this was the guy
who was he wanted to reform
the criminal justice system in san
francisco um he wanted to reform it till
there was none like he was
he was basically he was like if you get
stabbed he was like hey that's part of
it calm down
and he treated
he treated the drug addicts in san
francisco kind of the way
i treat my friends that aren't on drugs
i ignore them and i don't care what
happens to them
and i don't care who they hurt and how
so chesaputin uh they got him out of
there because people got sick of
this idea that you're just gonna let the
uh drug problem the fentanyl problem
uh
it's becoming so bad
in san francisco right now
um
because there are no republicans that
live there nobody lives there as a
republican it is the vast majority of
people are somewhere on the left
and
they threw
because if you're like if you're a
hardcore republican you left already you
you know
so they threw them out
um
because uh they were sick of
these open-air drug markets because san
francisco there's this harm reduction
policy
they have that allows people on drugs
to just kind of
use drugs
and they create areas for them to use
drugs safely
and many of these people od
and die
because
you know
it's easier for them
to use drugs in san francisco than
another city
and
you know it's sad right it's a difficult
it's a difficult thing
it's a tough thing to to know what to do
because fentanyl is good
and people that do it for the most part
are happy with it
and
i have recommended to my friends that
they should look into
getting a drug addiction because it's
not a bad way to die it's a very sexy
and kind of
heroin chic glamorous be to be a real
junkie on the street with your [ __ ] out
and bleeding and spitting and screaming
and there's something i like about i've
always liked this and i've told you that
i'm too old for this behavior of course
but but there's something about being a
young like rent you know daphne ruben
vegan rent we've got a big puerto rican
tits out and she's got aids there's
something about that that i think is
nice
and i don't want to lose that part of
san francisco like i there's something
about like a real junkie like a real
junkie who comes in her house and her
mother goes where have you been she goes
yeah i don't understand me and she goes
in and she locks herself in a room and
she just cries her mascara off in the
tub
and nobody knows what's torturing her
but it's
it's it's because somebody you know
touched her inappropriately years ago at
a summer camp but she can never she can
ever get that out but she writes a poem
about it like she writes like a like a
you go three stanza poem and they decode
it after her death and go [ __ ] frank
fingered her once and the thing and she
went nuts but whatever it is there's
something deep and dark and sexy and
important about that type of behavior
and i don't want to get rid of all
addict behavior i don't i think it's
important for children specifically
children to see
people in the streets flailing their
arms foaming at the mouth seizing up
breaking into cars i do think it's
important to see that for children
specifically children so that they can
decide kind of which way in life they
want to go
i do like that i do like a little bit of
gotham city after the light has gone
down i do like a little bit of that now
it's going to be very difficult to keep
that
because it is hurting people and people
are angry with it and i and i completely
understand there's a lot of homeless
people in california
tons i have a friend here now from
ireland and i'm showing them
all the different places and and you
know people are
they're stunned by the inequality
they're stunned by the inequality in the
country even with the tense the
inequality some people have very big
tents it's almost like a small home and
some people just lay right out on the
street
so the inequality is even present in the
unhoused community there's so much
inequality even with the unhoused
because some people have these beautiful
structures they've built really attached
to overpasses and things some people are
living in cars and then we saw a woman
take her pants off right out on the
street today
and a lot of these people are in a bad
situation and some of them
um
are gonna be because rick caruso now is
coming rick caruso was the mayor
of the grove and he he built something
called the grove everyone in l.a loves
the grove i've only been to the grove
once or twice but you you people like
you like to grow right isn't it that's
who it's for you nice it's a nice isn't
it for you and your wife and people like
that just they have a movie theater uh
they have sprinkles cupcakes right this
is my point so they love it
you know what i mean like him and his
wife people like that there's nothing
wrong with them these are the people
that there's nothing wrong with them you
know what i mean they get they put the
fuel in the plane
listen
but look to show them a photo of this
the grove here because it's uh it's
stunning it's like europe
it's like paris
oh my god
it's like paris except you're in la
that's what's so special about it
and it's it's like european and sexy
remember when we saw sebastian
maniscalco there once and he didn't make
eye contact with us
love it
now
at the grove uh rick caruso he's a
billionaire uh developer right
we've talked about him on the show
what happened with him he just had they
had an election i'd barely pay attention
to what goes on here because i i'm i'm
like i don't know i've got my i'm one
foot out of here
i'm one toe in one toe out
tell the people what happened i have no
voice so uh 42 the 37 percent rick won
by five percent but since it's not an
overwhelming majority of 50 how it works
in mayoral races is that it's going to
run too uh
going to go into a runoff that was my
november being blown
so rick caruso is the mayor of the grove
in los angeles he owns this big uh
he owns this thing with stores right and
there's a trolley there is a trolley so
there's a trolley that'll take you there
see right there bad ass around and the
troll you get off the trolley you go
right into a store
and you buy something
well it's lovely now
he's the mayor of the grove and now he
wants to be the mayor of los angeles
california and people are upset with the
homeless they're angry with the homeless
um
and
i get it i get it because it's it's
gross here
it's truly disgusting here to show
anyone the city is gross
it's embarrassing
we went down to santa monica and there's
just people in the middle of the street
screaming going
but part of why i don't get as angry
about that
is it seems appropriate
right like for the culture that we've
created doesn't it seem a little
appropriate
wouldn't it be weirder if people weren't
in the middle of the street screaming
it be and i'm not saying that this is a
nice place but i think the
i mean
you know i i'm just
this is the result of years and years
and years and years of not giving a [ __ ]
about any of the problems right
so like when people just go you know the
homeless right now it's a big problem
i go yes it is but it's also
the result
of many many years of people not caring
about anything
at all
and so what that's resulted in is this
societal uh collapse so it didn't happen
yesterday it's not like a bunch of
people yesterday just were like [ __ ]
houses
i'm out now what has happened is we've
made it easier for drug addicts to do
drugs and buy drugs in the street not
good
i don't like that
but
[ __ ] i don't know legalize drugs
put them you know what i mean
get the methadone clinics going figure
it out
build housing for them
kill them like the asians do
they don't [ __ ] with go the other way
you don't want to go the other way go
the other way
kill them the asians will kill them
singapore right they'll just kill them
death penalty yeah give them the death
penalty then i don't really know
which way to go
i'm divided
either
legalize drugs and compassionately like
hold their hand
and put them in a nice place and maybe
suggest they don't do it like lightly go
you don't have to do that
there is a place for you to do it if you
want but you don't have to or just shoot
him in the back of the head
like or you know what i mean like they
do in indonesia right like you have a
military hunter that just kills them
i don't know what to do i'm i it's
either or
it's either it's either one because the
in the middle doesn't seem to work
in the middle doesn't seem to work
because i guess that's what we're doing
now
so you have to kill them all
like they do in like indonesia
or
you have to build like affordable
housing and then like
get high with them
well i don't mean homeless people but i
mean drugs sure sure
like drugs i'm not listen there's a lot
of reasons people are homeless
it could be everything from you have a
crippling drug addiction to they were a
horrible podcast producer
there's a lot of reasons people end up
on the street
more than 7 000 killed in the
philippines in six months as a president
encourages murder i gotta be honest they
keep telling me not to like this guy
this guy's a very interesting person
rodrigo duterte
um
now why are they killing the people is
there a reason for it so it says this is
from 2017 uh he ordered the police to
kill anyone they believed to be
connected to the drugs trade when he
assumed office in june 2016. so
according to police counts in the
philippines
7 00 25 people were killed by the police
or unknown armed attackers in the war on
drugs between july 1st and january 30th
it's a hardline approach 34 days it's a
hard-line approach
hard-line approach here and that's one
way to do it right you could kill them
all and even people that are just near
them
but there's got to be a better way than
that perhaps but maybe not
i don't know i'm not an expert in this
like this chessa boudin he's a real
problem
but
like
if i was
a mayor of san francisco
i don't know what i would do
i don't
because i don't really like san
francisco
i don't mind it it's it's foggy and cold
i like sea lions when they're on a wharf
you know the when they're on a wharf
it's kind of filthy they're kind of a
filthy animal yeah
but and i don't like the hills so my
point is i don't i don't even know what
i would do
about the whole thing marin county's
nice but you know the tech people bother
me
what's worth saving is my point i don't
know what i don't know if i'm into it
so i mean i'm just saying why not give
these people a section of the city like
an entire section i think they have
actually in san francisco i think they
have given them
what i mean is like
give them give them
[Music]
a part of the city
where when they can't go anywhere else
i mean is that a good idea like
you draw a line around this area and
they go listen this is where you get
[ __ ] up
this is where you get [ __ ] up but you
can't leave
and you just get [ __ ] up in this part
is that is that rational like uh like
chas or something like that like one of
those well
you you you you make it
for them
you design it
like that's what i thought rick caruso
was gonna do
was design a whole area for them with a
trolley and everything because they i
think they'd like to trolley they could
get on and off
and
what i'm imagining
is that rick garus is going to lock
these people in a room and burn them all
and you might have to here's my thing
there might not be a better way to do it
you might have to just genocide
everybody
i don't know i mean it seems
it seems
mean
and you'd have to explain it to your
kids you'd have to go that was mean
we did a thing that was mean
why did you do
we did a genocide of all of the homeless
people
but
i don't i i mean i'm so out of ideas on
this i'm i'm i'm so
all over the place
you know
we don't have a lot of
vigilantism right which is nice
there's not a lot of people like driving
around setting homeless people on fire
no it's not really a thing that's not
really and i'm not saying to do that
would it hurt
yes
i'm just saying that that's
that's there's ideas to that right where
you go well i'll just start lighting
them up
like that's an idea
it's not good i'm going to ideas
i'm not going through the good ideas i'm
going through all of the ideas
um
why don't we do like a thing where we
take like tai lopez
gary vanyuck
grant cardone all these sales trainers
and do a big reality show called
america's
next top
homeless entrepreneur
and it's a show
where we select 10
unhoused people
to compete to become an entrepreneur we
have kris jenner
as a guest judge
it's shot in la it's shot in the mecca
of homelessness it's shot in the
ground zero
if you will r.p to all those people who
pretended to die
but
why not
do a show
why not do a show where you have
homeless people in l.a
flocking
i want every homeless person in america
in l.a we've got 70 percent i want a
hundred percent
and i want them here and i want to
embrace homelessness instead of like
like instead of like i have to be
embarrassed when i'm driving this this
dude around going like oh yeah this is
homeless i want to be like yeah
yeah yeah it's the place for all why not
be like the place for homeless people
have a big show like a big reality show
have homeless village like entire
villages and it can have class structure
in the unhoused community
like basically
like why not embrace it why not have
that be our thing
be like we have more people without
homes than any other city
in this whole [ __ ] dump of a country
we have more homeless people
but i think it's a great idea america's
and you know all of these sales trainers
and motivational speakers
can can really
coach
these homeless
fentanyl addicts
whose minds were scrambled in many of
our illegal and amoral wars
and
like and they would scream at them
they'd go just stay on brand and like a
guy would go
he's like he's selling vests you know
he'd be like they told me to do things
in iraq
i didn't want to do them
i didn't wanna i can't stop hearing the
voice and then like like gary v and
grant cardone everybody be like just
stay on brand
stay on brand
and and that would be
that would be nice because then the
homeless people would have to remember
oh [ __ ] yeah that's not fun nobody likes
that nobody wants that i have to be but
i mean i if there's there's there's got
to be a route for a lot of these
homeless
people to develop their own sense of
self-worth
through american capitalism
capitalism has to save the day here and
i think it can
if we start a big reality show where
psychopathic homeless people
attack each other and vilify each other
on camera
to show who can withstand
that really really
that gauntlet
of really tough [ __ ] that it takes to be
a [ __ ] killer
because i'm getting sick of this
i'm getting sick of feeling bad for the
unhoused
and i'm getting sick of it
i want them on television
now
if we're not gonna kill them
i want them to be on tv because i've
always wanted to be on tv
and i think being on tv is nice
i think it's a nice thing
and i think if you live in los angeles
it always crosses your mind
and i think
there's a lot of great shows here
and there's a great show
about homeless people
just put the cameras in the tents
select a few of them select
a few what about a homeless big brother
10 people in like a big tent
in a really big tent
in a parking lot
and at the end of the show
we burn it down
and it seems like
it seems cruel but then the reality is
they're all like they escape we go
congrats now you have houses
but isn't it nice so they run out of the
tent and it's full of smoke and stuff
and then they get there and they go now
you have
houses now you have homes
i don't know what to do i'm just saying
it this whole thing here has gotten so
uh
problematic
that
i'm i'm unaware of what to do i don't
know what to do all i can say
is that uh
i'm hopeful
i mean so many people right now they're
working too much they're stressed out
they're not taking enough time for
themselves have you ever felt burned out
what did it feel like to you
i felt sad stressed stretched too thin
better help
it's online therapy they want to remind
you to prioritize yourself
talking with somebody can help you
talk about your personal experience with
another person
who's there to help you
it's customized online therapy it offers
video phone even live chat sessions with
your therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours
our listeners get 10 off their first
month at
timdy that's
betterhlp.com tim d
have you ever been sad oh yeah have you
ever been mad oh yeah have you ever felt
bad yeah yeah and what do you do
i use better help and then what happened
i feel better you feel good
you feel in the hood
sure
you feel with the wood
oh yeah
so this is the what rick caruso is
promising
if elected mayor
he is going to
this is again this is from his mouth he
said he's going to quote separate the
men from the boys
and this is some of the
so these are some of the
these are his programs
these are some of his policies
that he's gonna do right here
um this is very interesting
again this is a
yeah so he said that one
that's gonna be uh
they're gonna do that
down by hollywood
this is gonna be down in venice beach
this one
there you go see that right there venice
beach clear everybody out
again these are summer and and we may
need it it may need to happen all right
it may need to happen i don't know what
to do anymore
the left doesn't they don't make any
sense they're like just let people [ __ ]
on the street and do heroin
and the rights like make all those
people subscribe to the daily wire and
start businesses
none of it's right
the cops aren't going to be able to
solve everything because you know how'd
they do that yuvaldi by the way
isn't it great and i understand the need
to have comps i keep you know people
think i'm a fascist because they say we
need police
um but this uvalde thing really shows
you that there are some cops out here
that it's just not great
ivaldi school's police chief i didn't
know i was in charge of the shooting
scene yeah well
yep it's a lot of you know
all we hear is how brave to come you
know everybody's brave and the cops are
brave and
you know
it's brave they just didn't you know
they didn't do anything
but
yeah i mean you know what are you what
are you gonna do run into school
he should say that he should go what did
you expect me to do like run in the
school
save your own kids
these are all the brave police that
didn't run into the school
i have friends that are cops all my
friends are cops like
they would run into school and start
shooting the kids because they're so
it's crazy
but
you know i mean
what if homeless people
guarded schools
and we paid them to do that because
they're like terrifying and you'd have
to shoot through them to get to the kids
what if you had to shoot through
homeless people to get to the kids
i mean is that a bad idea to just have a
bunch of homeless people outside of a
school
you'd have to shoot through them like as
a shield
use homeless people as a human shield
to protect the children
there's worse ideas
than the ones i'm talking about
francis ellis is coming up he's a fun
guy from barcelona sports we've got a
musical guest the episode isn't that
long tonight cause i can't talk
i can't [ __ ] speak
i just wanted to come in here and
celebrate uh
what was i what are we celebrating we're
celebrating uh uh well there's a lot to
celebrate i suppose like what uh it's
pride weekend this weekend oh it's pride
month it's a whole month yeah well
they're doing their pride parade this
weekend it's a it's a pride parade you
think rick caruso will be at that
gay people love him they all they're all
rich yeah they're all lying oh come on
oh yeah who cares
well the four fat lesbians on twitter
who write for
like no one respects who write for these
shows nobody watches on hulu and these
garbage shows on [ __ ] fox and [ __ ]
he's for fat non-binary people they
don't like him yeah but a lot of gay
people are rich and they want caruso
when they're putting homeless in a
frying pan
so i mean let's cut it out
you think gay people left their homes in
middle of america
you know where their parents hated them
they came here they got successful so
that they could step and piss and [ __ ]
this is you know what i mean that this
this isn't they don't want that
but of course there's like some fat
unicorn on twitter
who's like you know it's just some fat
woman who's cross-eyed
tweeting about how rick caruso's like
you know
the [ __ ] you know
boston strangler
who's the one from london
oh the jack the ripper yeah she's like
jacked a ripper and
gay people don't care so rick caruso go
down there in suits you're just
putting hundreds and like twinks [ __ ]
g-strings
daddy caruso
you think rick caruso will go down there
and full leather is like a leather daddy
that'd be great
if he's on a float
with billionaires you're all just
throwing money
he's dressed up like a leather daddy
and he's like i'm gonna make this city
safe
so you can get sucked off in a park
again
he gives a big speech
he's gonna this city used to be a place
where you could go get aids in a park
quietly
without worrying if some [ __ ]
schizophrenic was gonna throw his own
[ __ ] at you unless you were into that
getting [ __ ] thrown at you used to be
something that was pre-arranged in this
city
now it's not
i want to make this city safe
for random strangers to suck each
other's [ __ ] without knowing each
other's names
on benches again the way it used to be
i want to make this city safe
where women and children were horribly
abused by rich people
and thrown into the street to deal with
it
i want to make this city safe
for the people that made great art like
harvey weinstein
kevin spacey brett ratner and others
i want to make this city safe
you know
people like brian singer
would take you know 15 year olds i got
here from omaha
drugged them up and used them like
popsicles
i want this city safe like he's doing
the speech
because i want this city safe
because it's been taken over by fat
lesbians with no sense of humor
that's not what la's about
it's about [ __ ] with guns
people
clapping with a baby who's crying
there's
are
he's like the movies we make are [ __ ]
now
the tv shows suck
he goes if you're anything like me you
gotta watch a filipino maid got beat to
death on the dark web to come
nobody's clapping
he goes if you want to laugh now you
just have to watch old [ __ ] videos at
9 11.
he goes you can't even laugh unless
you're watching 9 11 videos if you're
anything like me people are going you
[ __ ] yeah wreck
this city's gone in a bad direction
he goes this is a city
of beautiful people it's been taken over
by ugly untalented monsters
i want fat people out of here
i want fat people to feel the shame they
felt when i first moved here where a fat
woman would break down in tears after
what i would say to her at a grocery
store
i want that l.a back people are just
screaming caruso
i want cruelty back
i want evil back
by the way i would vote for him if he
did this
i bet i don't i don't even live here but
i'm saying
the reality is
that's what we need like an inspiring
speech about what l.a is
he's like la's a city about people that
move here to become something and in
order to do that they destroy everything
about themselves
and then they become something
completely different than the thing they
were
they reinvent themselves
and then at the end of their lives they
all get trapped in these big mansions
and they end up in pools
nobody understands what it's like to be
them
and they're just
[ __ ] paranoid demons
and then people want to be them and they
move here
they befriend these demons
that's what la is it's a city about
freedom
he goes it's the greatest city in the
world
hella is such a great city
he just starts screaming his eye
he goes i want blood
i want blood again
people are like yeah this is beautiful
i mean maybe he'll go down there pride
pride week give real speech
he's like lesbians used to be in the
valley keep their mouths shut
this city is about closeted ceos
getting sucked off
by [ __ ] coked out rent boys he's
clamping
it's not about fat lesbian comedy riders
who look like [ __ ]
they look like [ __ ]
they have no sense of humor they're
gross they should be in new york
everyone's clapping
i don't care where you went to school
that's new york [ __ ]
we don't have school shootings our kids
are too stupid
they're all on only fans you can't
traffic our kids they traffic themselves
people clapping
thank you rick
my son's a dj for christ's sake
[Applause]
but i mean you know we wish it well
he'll be fine
he'll be fine he's going to be okay
isn't it
isn't it going to be okay it's going to
be okay
he had francis ellis coming up here
barstool sports what did he do he hit a
woman ahead with a brick or something
whatever they don't let him work anymore
he hit a woman in the head with a brick
i don't know what he did he must have
done something oh he made a joke on a
blog about a woman who's dead
well
what are you gonna do rick russo laughed
rick caruso
you should have a you should have a
video
where a campaign ad where it's just some
models like sucking them off you just
see your head going up and down and he's
got a gun to her head like this
as he's going up and down and he goes
you know my favorite thing about l.a
because some people say it's the weather
because you know what i like about it
you just see her head bobbing up and
down he's got a gun right on her head
he's like you know what i really like
about la
he goes i liked it it goes it goes uh he
goes it's something that just gets in ya
you can't really explain what it is it's
just a certain magic that the city has
you know and her head is just
and he's like okay
get ready i'm close and he's just
jamming the gun in her head he goes i'm
close
i'm close
and it's like this ad was paid by for
rick caruso
um
he'll be fine
this city is gonna be fine he'll solve
it all if he gets elected
what do you what's a serious proposal
for the homeless
what what can you really do i was
reading uh in santa monica how they
solved it in the 90s how'd they do it
they ship them off where do they go i
think palmdale
they always put them in palmdale yeah
they give them a free bus pass and they
just ship them off somewhere else
interesting yeah i looked up the most
homeless people are in santa cruz
outside san francisco and i think my
theory is they must just bust them down
there because it's outside san jose they
must just keep pushing them
further and further
south interesting
i don't know what to do
part of me thinks
we should just have like burn pits where
we just burn them alive
and part of me thinks
we have to build affordable housing
it's
between those two
ideas one of them would be a burn pad
where they would be burned
alive
and then used to fertilize can you fuse
people's fertilizer i don't think after
you burn them oh interesting
i'm trying to avoid comparison to the
holly i don't want it to feel like the
holocaust if we burn these people
is there a way to do a death camp that's
not reminiscent of the holocaust for
homeless people in l.a like is there a
way to do it where it does it's not like
holocaust vibes
yeah
there's a way to do right yeah yeah you
could use uh water like a drowning well
somebody told me about this thing called
doula it was this um
this thing i didn't invest in but it's
water cremation oh
water cremation now because it's better
for the environment so what if we just
use water to cremate homeless people you
cook them in a pot
oh so if we cook them in a pot
you can cook people in a pot
right
so i don't know i i've there's two
i have two ideas
one is that we cook them in a pot
number two like a very big industrial
pot like it's one of the biggest pots
you've ever seen and we cook people in
it
the other thing is that we try to build
affordable housing
and get them in that
but i don't
but i don't know
do you know what i mean because that
might not work we may have to do the pot
anyway so you just do the pot now
that's my whole thing with the
affordable housing it may not work so do
you just do the pot now
can this be a real issue because some of
the people in the crowd are gonna go do
the pot
just do the pot now and i'm gonna go
because we could do one or two things i
would give people the option i'd go if i
was a cruiser i'd go we could build
affordable housing or we could put the
people in this pot that we've built
and cremate them using water high
pressure water at a high heat we
we stew them alive
and or we could do this
housing where we build 30 units of and
then people just start yelling do the
pot rick
[Music]
rick
do the pot
well we could try to get them in
we'll put them in a job training program
what kind of water goes in the pot
are you sure they won't survive
they can't get out right
well we could then maybe
when we're in a job training program we
offer incentives to companies to then
hire them but what do you do with the
waste from the pot
after they've been dealt with
i mean
all i can say is uh that
i hope everyone is well
happy uh pride
to everyone
why are you laughing no it's just it's
it's it's very funny to say all those
things and then wish uh people well
well what are you gonna do people need
to be wished well
people need that
people need that in their lives i just
want to get like so low i want to be so
like out of it where i just
like i'm like kind of like this i want
to broadcast like this like to the end
like
i got like
look at the indigo ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the tim dillon show
the homeless have breached the studio
again
what about what about barry wise can't
she go out and give these homeless
people a talking to
what if she goes out and gives him a
talking to
you know uh her wife nellie bowles wrote
a
a good thing about the san francisco
homeless
it was about how san francisco became
she wrote something about the homeless
in san francisco
and i read the article it was pretty
good
in the atlantic
maybe
yes yes
how san francisco became a failed city
and how it could recover
now i wanted to hire a homeless person
to write a like a rebuttal
called san francisco is great g-r-a-t-e
she makes some points here but the
homeless
you know 117 thousand dollar salary
counts as low income for a family of
four in san francisco
it's crazy yeah that's nuts
it's so [ __ ] nuts right
it's crazy
it's a good article yeah
and she writes about
um
how san francisco became such a problem
and then what to do about it
and her idea
is basically if you get a big pot
i'm kidding
i'm kidding you can't put people in a
big pot
but
like what would you have to do you'd
have to get them
you have to sweep them off the streets
and then you'd have a big beautiful like
a like picture a chemical treatment
facility
where they'd be dissolved very quickly
you'd throw them in something that would
dissolve their bones and skin
and teeth
but where would that waste go
could you shoot it into space
so what you would do essentially is you
would dissolve the people in a pot
and then you would shoot
you would shoot their waste into space
yeah you could i guess you could profit
off of it maybe like if you turn it into
vitamins or
pills maybe of some kind
you wouldn't go in immediately you'd get
a few chances
but like on the third and then the cops
would also have that over your head they
go you go into the pot
if you if third time
third time's a charm third time's a pot
people in the street be like yo that
[ __ ] went to the pot
[Laughter]
and we would we would use chemicals to
dissolve people
and they would go away
it's a thought
it's a thought
i remember caruso is like
she's like remember
when your mother or she goes i'm italian
your mother would have a pot of sauce
we got a pot of problems
but we're going to dissolve people their
skin and their bones and their teeth
using a high
highly effective and environmentally
safe chemical
that allows people
to be dissolved within a matter of
minutes and eliminated from our society
never to be seen or heard from and every
person that gets dissolved
they like do a little nice thing like
you do like a nice
it's like there's a thing that happens
it's not like a total loss okay
there's like a rib they put a ribbon
around a fence or something
and then we just have a very long fence
and every time we dissolve a human being
we put a ribbon around the fence
because it's not it's not going to get
better if we don't
start thinking about how to dissolve
people
in a pot
people can get mad at this
and people can get offended at it
but what else are you gonna do
what are you gonna do
give give them all jobs at geico
put them in a pot
the judge looks at you right in the eye
you go to a court
and she goes it's your third time here
and you know what that means
you go into the pot
and the person goes
and then she just
clicks the gavel and there's no appeals
you don't even spend the night in jail
you're taken from the courthouse to the
pot
immediately before you know it before
you know what happens they they they hit
you
while you're standing there in court
they hit you with a uh
a tranquilizer
and then you wake up for a minute
right before like it's it's a maybe an
hour tranq
you wake up for a minute you're in a
little cell
and there's a door
and the cell gets really really like hot
like your feet you gotta like
you gotta open the door
so you end up opening the door and then
you just youth
it's kind of like
there's like a wall that pushes you out
and you go right into the pot
right into the bottom
and you're dissolved immediately
instantaneously
this is jobs
this is a great way to to figure it out
and if a lot of people out there are
interested in this and excited about
this
write to rick caruso
tweeted him
go i heard
i'm very excited
about your your your new program to
dissolve
the homeless people using chemicals can
you go into this
can you speak on this
rick i was at a party in hancock park
and one of my friends said he was going
to be working for the company that
provides you the chemicals
in which you were going to dissolve the
homeless people
once they had had their last shot
they're going right to the pot
that could be a slogan
caruso what's his slogan now does he
have one
he's gonna have something right he
doesn't really have one huh
for the love of l.a i think that's it
yeah
you know what i think it should be
to the pot
rick cruz so you go to the pot
go up for a second
oh that's nice
oh that is nice that's sweet
it's everybody at the grove it's
everyone in the grove it's all the
employees of the grove who said you're
all fired
if you don't get out into the street
with dodgers jerseys look as hispanic as
possible and endorse me right now
that guy in the wheelchair looked at
ricky goes hey rick i really enjoyed
this photo shoot can i have the rest of
the day off it goes get the get the [ __ ]
back and work right now i'll kill you
you want to go to the pot
and if the pot works in la it's pots for
everyone pots for san francisco
dallas will have a pot they'll already
put in a pot oh yeah they'll put it
they'll put in a frying pot
that's cause we fry people here in oil
this is a good story
rick's grandparents came to america from
italy
through ellis island
they were very big supporters of
mussolini
that's weird to put in the bio but it's
funny
his father served in world war ii
even though he disagreed with america's
stance
it's honest
it's very funny this is a bio
in 1997 rick founded caruso creating
tens of thousands of jobs and building
some of southern california's most
beloved community centers
uh including the grove
he served two stints at the department
of water and power reformed the lapd and
oversaw a 30 reduction in crime as
president of the la police i mean he
probably will clean the city listen
la needs somebody and it probably has to
be this guy because things are really
bad i just hope he gets a pot
and cooks people in it
today he's running for mayor of l.a to
put an industry homelessness make our
community safer
clean up corruption
and construct a very large pot
in which he will use
environmentally safe chemicals to
dissolve
homeless people immediately on contact
wow
rick caruso
he's a good man
he does he probably does need to win as
much as we joke he probably does
need to win because
you know i don't know what what else
there is here to do
i know i'm not a friend i like when i'm
out of frame like this
it's very funny
it's funnier it's funnier to not be in
the frame
it's funnier to be completely out of
frame like this
like that's a better show to just do
this
because you know people get mad when we
don't do audio when we do audio only
episodes there's something funny about
me being just completely out of frame
for the entire episode
it's great comedy
this important psa is brought to you by
manscape.com this is your public pubic
service announcement
and the news you've been waiting for the
manscape engineering team has confirmed
that they have successfully created the
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer which is now
available for purchase in the usa and
canada this new trimmer was just
released only moments ago and we were
the first to get our hands on it and
share the news just over 2 million men
worldwide who trust manscape with this
exclusive offer for you
20 off and free worldwide shipping by
going to manscape.com tim day
i'm one of the first people to try it
i'm blown away by the performance of
craftsmanship the details on the 4.0
their next level
their next level
i'm telling you right now it's
waterproof you can groom in the shower
and not have to worry about making a
mess on the bathroom floor
okay
if you're still trimming your face with
your ball trimmers time to make some
changes
everybody needs manscape everybody wants
to support our show it's a great way to
support the show it's the best
trimmer that you can get your hands on
get 20 off and free worldwide shipping
by going to manscape.comd
no person wants to end up with pubes in
their mouth and your balls will thank
you
get 20 off in free worldwide shipping by
going to manscape.com chimndy that's 20
off
and free worldwide shipping by going to
manscape.combee
unlock your confidence and always use
the right tools for the job with
manscaped
i love raycon earbuds i tell people all
the time they are less expensive than
the earbuds that we all know what we're
talking about
these are the best earbuds to have
they're better
eight hours of play time 32 hour battery
life
when you need to charge it's super easy
you can even do it wirelessly it's a
huge
selling point red counts you get the
same quality audio as other premium
audio brands but half the price
yes really but that doesn't mean they
won't last
i mean man
recons if they fall they get lost in the
rain and snow storms they still work
afterwards it's no wonder raycon's
everyday earbuds have over 49 000
five-star reviews
i only have raycon do you only have
raycon right now yeah i mixed the show
with the raycons i love their icons
check out raycon's wireless earbuds my
guess is that you're going to want to
leave them a five star review too go to
buy raycon.com
tim today to get 15 off your raycon
order that's by raycon dot com slash tim
the court to score
15
off that's by raycon.com tim to score 15
off by raycon.com
tim
francis alice joins us blogger at one
time at barcelo sports you had a
incident that changed your life
can you go into that a little bit sure
um i wrote a blog about a woman a woman
who was missing in utah her sorority
sisters had
told the fbi she was missing right so
there was sort of this legally blonde
element that i thought was funny it's
funny yeah and then uh i just wrote a
blog and two hours after i wrote it she
was found brutally murdered
and then i obviously looked
tasteless uh in in after the fact it's
unfortunate and i was fired uh and you
yes were one of the first people to call
me yes to let me know that the world had
not ended right you know in batman yeah
when he says yeah a hero can be anybody
even someone putting a coat over a boy's
shoulders to let him know that his his
world hasn't ended right and you were
that for me
right what did i say again you called me
and you said buddy what happened and you
told me that my life wasn't over right
because all i was seeing were
torrents of horrific
headlines about what a monster i was how
could i possibly have done this uh you
know what probably happened
what's really fun is when these things
happen you call the person you go it's
gonna be okay then you call six other
people and go they are so [ __ ]
like i think i did that i think i called
like seven people i was like that guy's
[ __ ]
and then i think i called you and i went
it's gonna be fine yeah because that's
what most of us do yeah i was calling
people that didn't even know you i'm
like he's shot
he's completely [ __ ]
i didn't know that so but that's what
everyone does that's what we ever it's
what everyone does i call everyone and
tell them they're gonna be okay cause
it's true it meant a lot to me it well i
was right yeah you were nobody things
are better now yeah right yeah nobody
nobody they moved on to far
more torn up pastures i guess there's
other problems yeah the epstein story
broke three days after my you wonder if
it was three days before you might have
been okay it's a good question you ever
think about that yeah
mine would have been lost in the show 72
hours maybe no one cared i know i wonder
does portnoy ever say to you like hey
i'm sorry it went down like that no yeah
and business insider they tried to run a
hit piece on me
is that right yeah
this guy that used to work for them was
a
comic it didn't work out amazing
and he went to go work for business
insider and he called me did an
hour-long interview with me
they uh said hey
will
and i called him like seven months later
i went what the [ __ ] yeah there you go
tim dillon blows whistle on business
insiders failed hit pieces oh i remember
that i i called the uh writer back and i
went hey what happened
and the writer said they were
uninterested because he goes i
interviewed you for an hour and i didn't
come to the conclusion that you were
like a right-wing psychopath
so they didn't want to run the article
unless it was that angle wait what is
that kyle written house tweet they have
for me not sure
kyle written else was crying because he
accidentally misgendered a court clerk
that kind of responsibility is rare to
see in young men who could get angry at
that i mean who could
why would anyone be mad at that
they put that and i mean
um
i don't even go on twitter too much
anymore i just we tweet the clips
taking a minute good it's just too much
you've earned it i've earned a minute
and then we'll see what's gonna happen
but now this has changed your life now
you're actually working on things that
are very important to society at large
that's right
and what what are they well let's call
it a white a large pr tour you're like
white yes you're rich
right i mean i i i'm am i allowed to say
that sure
you're
kind of like a yale legacy
uh i went to harvard okay harvard i
apologize but no one in my family did
interest so you were the first one they
were all yale okay that's what i thought
yeah you because i did your podcast
years and years ago your grandfather was
like one of the founding guys of the cia
right he was in skull and bones skull
busters and they went to cia yeah
interesting so it's amazing that you do
this isn't that amazing a little yeah
then it went from that to this
isn't that the american empire it's the
end of it really the guy's got a
keyboard we're in hollywood he's doing a
thing anyway but the point is you could
be in morocco stabbing someone with a
poison pen
but
but you're here now and it's what's
important it's what your grandfather
came to this country for you to do is
play on a keyboard yeah now
he is i mean he wasn't his we've been
here a long time he was not he did not
come together we didn't come here he's
he's a pilgrim right he's one of those
guys yeah but i mean come and
come in there spiritually from europe
you know this is why they they came here
eventually so that we could do this
it is true we have the privilege
to do fake
business for years and years
i love the fake i know it's it's i've
done it myself we have a line that's
coming out we have a clothing line it's
it's very good but we have another one
now happening
um
what
what you call people up sometimes and
[ __ ] with them well i i when i was doing
stand-up in new york early on i was
tutoring right and i started a tutoring
company right this is a small thing yeah
to just make us more legit sure and uh i
then called all of the sort of most
prestigious tutoring agencies in new
york yes posing as a father
to find out their rates yeah and their
like techniques and things and i would
describe my daughter
having severe needs educationally and
get the price points and all of that and
i mean it was fun so used to figure out
where you needed to be
yeah right it was fun pretending to be a
dad and it's always fun lie to these
agencies it's always fun to make fun to
make up things yeah it's great it really
is it's always fun to waste people's
time yeah it's the only reason we're
here on earth
i love it so now you're doing this new
thing and you're you're finally or
you've finally realized you're white man
after all these years i was told i did
not choose it i know so you finally
you figured it out yeah you're like i'm
a privileged [ __ ] guy
but then so now you're embracing this
you've written a song about this
where because you've decided that you're
going to have the back
of people that have been historically
marginalized and that you kind of
understand what they're going through
yeah and i think more importantly i i
sort of saw the virtue of people who do
defend these people that's right more of
that i think that they're almost more
the people that defend them i think are
really more important even than the
people that are being abused for sure
because the people that defend them are
like oh my god wow and if they didn't we
wouldn't know that's right they put
themselves
in front of
the imaginary train yes that may or may
not be coming
that's amazing it's amazing that's
those are the people that i want to be
yeah the mouthpieces absolutely well i
drive my bentley through a bed area to
go to a taco truck and i see a pit bull
chasing a young girl
and i think
you know what i mean
i think hey
what's going on here it's what i say to
myself but why don't you tweet it i i
i'm not i'm trying to spend some time
off twitter but i when i see that i feel
like i should do more yes about that but
all it would take all it would take is a
tweet it's just to let people know that
there's young women being chased by dogs
it might have been her dog she was happy
and smiling
but the point is the whole the whole
thing threw me i didn't i didn't get it
also the law the lawn furniture was
oddly mismatched the point i didn't
understand was happening but the point
is it may not have been a violent thing
um but this song i i wanted to have you
on because it spoke to me and because it
really is about those people that go out
there
and they make a difference even if
they're just changing the perception of
who they are it's still important
it's important to be
like some of them are out right now
talking about the la sheriff's race i
didn't even know it was happening but
it's very important and there was a
virtual sheriff zoom the other day that
will should have joined to hear the
different sheriff candidates and what
they're gonna do about
uh nazi gangs in the lapd which
apparently are a lot of them too many
um but one of our one of the people i
know on instagram who's a television
writer is deeply involved in the
sheriff's race
in los angeles making sure that
everything's on the up and up more power
to them
um but i love this song because it
speaks uh to me it's the hero the heroic
group
out there have you ever spoken to that
girl's family that was brutally murdered
have you ever reached out you ever say
sorry
no
um humbly i believe that they probably
had too much going on to even have
notice no i don't think that's true
what your joke was the biggest thing of
that week for them
so if you could really i mean maybe go
visit them and bring cameras
and sit down with them
and film it and it would just be you
at their table
and just saying hi i'm francis ellis and
i made this joke i'm sorry about what
happened to your daughter
but i didn't kill her i made a joke and
have them forgive you for the joke
have them forgive you and like take your
hand it could be a beautiful moment i
wonder if enough time has passed good
question yeah
you might want to wait a little those
wounds might still be a little fragile
that's a good point and how did you i
mean this is sad the way it did it's sad
when anyone dies i've said that before
haven't i
yes you have at all well no and i've
meant that i'm not being physicians when
anyone dies there's a there's an element
of uh you go what you know and then it's
also sad
and it's very tough
it is i you know but it's shocking too
people found in parks it's crazy these
national parks aren't good for anyone
um
so please you play this song that i love
and love and love this is francis ellis
used to be from barcelona sports
before he made fun of the dead
uh and now where are you if people like
you
and want more of your thing
where can they find it yeah if if
someone goes my sister was just murdered
and i want you to get her
where can they get you where can they
hire you to do a roast of the dead
uh on on my podcast lovely it's called
oops the podcast oops the podcast this
is julio guys marketing back to
yeah oops the podcast and social media
wise if they want to find you uh francis
ellis you'll find me on you'll find them
twitter take it away this song's amazing
thanks tim
cop with me over and asked why i was
speeding
i said i'm headed to the mountain for a
big day of skiing he said i figured it
was that from the skis on your rack and
then we both kind of chuckled as he
handed me back
my license registration told me try to
slow down we've got a lot of people
speeding through the stretch of our town
i promised that i would have said i
understood
and i always try my best to drive the
way that i should
he said goodbye enjoy the slopes and i
drove off down the road but when i got
around the bend i put the pedal to the
floor and when i finally arrived i was
greeted by a sight that made me shiver
and quiver and shake with fright
cause the line at the chairlift was 50
people long by the time i took my first
run all the powder was gone
all because some local cop had to flex
on me
i'm just another victim
of brutality
brutality
[Applause]
it can happen to you if it happened to
me
i understand the nuances
of brutality
the winter is a time of darkness
when the sun goes down early and
everyone is heartless the days are short
and the nights are long and you'll wake
up with the feeling that it's all going
wrong when you feel like you're stuck in
a hole
and your brain starts to tell you it
can't take anymore and you no longer
care to learn what lies around the bend
so you start to think of ways to bring
your life to an end don't
instead
take a trip to tulum
find a beach in turks and caicos
snorkel la lagu
find that good wheat in jamaica
buy a house in southampton tim get that
going put your worries on the shelf
the purpose of mlk weekend is to utilize
your wealth
[Applause]
spend it on
yourself there's no price on mental
health
don't kill yourself
hey i'm a [ __ ] ally
now
and i feel it too and i'm here for you
online all the time every day around the
world a woman gets robbed she makes 30
less with the same exact job she endures
the horny glances the delusional
advances guys like hi my name is francis
from the toxic male mob but the time has
now come to bring the wage gap to an end
time to rip down these structures that
were only built for men time to take a
wrecking ball to the ancient patriarchy
say your boss sent you a dick pic at the
holiday party
a-l-l-y i'm a [ __ ] ally how
high i know just what you're going
through and i feel it too and i'm here
for you
online all the time
[Music]
she her he him they there animals are
friends not food jada pink it's lack of
hair and me too save ukraine put a stop
to asian hatred microplastics
overfishing bloggers who joke about
missing women man spreading on public
transit leah thomas you penn swimming
n double acp border family separations
joe rogan's misinformation spreading
fears of vaccination cultural
appropriation louis ck's masturbation me
me look at me
i'm so full of empathy i'm on the right
side of history just like and share my
tweet tweet
[Applause]
[Music]
and i feel it too and i'm here for you
online all the time
[Music]
thank you
francis alice everybody we love that
thank you so much thank you for changing
your life
thank you for changing your life and
realizing that there's a lot of good
that can be done yes there's a lot of
good that can be done and you're doing
it i'm trying man yeah i didn't have a
choice no you're trying and that's
important yeah you know beautiful thank
you so much go find this guy on social
media go listen to his podcast francis
ellis thank you so much brother see you
guys